all right take care of essential workers
guys um okay
so a there is a device that you can buy
off of
amazon that'll have an app where you
it's basically a chastity bill
you put your dick in it and you can lock
it and through the app you can
open it or keep it locked so this is i
guess really popular in the bdsm
community
and so there are people who want to have
their dick locked you can
so you can't get hard you can't pee out
of it it's also
water resistant why would you do this
it's some people's kink brendan
wait what's bdsm uh so what does it
stand for
uh bondage
uh silent d is dominatrix i think
bondage discipline submission
so that a part of that community so
apparently it's
a pretty good popular
app for that community and what ended up
happening was
their server got hacked and the hacker
kept a bunch of people's dicks locked
and held hostage until they paid that
person in bitcoin
and at the time when they were sending
out these random messages
bitcoin uh the amount that they were
asking for was valued at seven hundred
fifty dollars
it's not terrible not terrible but at
the same time they can't pee out of it
either
you can pee in it but you're gonna have
piss everywhere because water resistant
you still can't get your dick out of it
oh
that's what we're gonna have to do are
you here you would keep it on i
pee i would like dude really are you
serious i'd be hard
dude i'd fry the system man
i don't know exactly how it works from
the photos but
it's supposed to lock your dick into
place i wonder if we can google an image
of like oh
okay so you see that place at the bottom
your balls go down there
yeah and then the penis goes in the
front and then the front is like a hatch
that won't fit for mine that's what i'm
gonna say it's gonna be a touch they
probably have different sizes
oh okay yeah and then but then how does
it stay on and all that yeah
well he asked for i believe it was point
zero two
bitcoin which valued at 750.
and so the person who sent out that
message their username on the platform
was
smelly and they sent the message your
car your [ __ ] is mine now to the victims
your [ __ ] is mine now yeah that's
terrifying but also
if you're into that that might be great
i don't no
it's got music to it have you ever
wanted to lock your penis
we've got the solution for you over here
at cellmate
are you man enough oh definitely you
have different sizes okay
but what if this thing didn't fit oh boy
a ring that best fits you
so it goes around your nuts and oh oh
you're nuts man
wow it's like a vibe it's why it's
harder to get off awesome it must be so
uncomfortable
that's terrifying tell you what ladies
when we keep man from cheating
put that damn thing lock it up yeah nah
they'll still find a way
how no over that thing oh my goodness
this
sweater oh now it started soaking
yeah so it's wrapped around your balls
it looks like there is a pee hole yeah
on that one
on that one on the one you showed there
wasn't yeah it didn't look like there
was a pee hole in there
it's pretty sweet this one looks like a
physical chastity belt the other one
looks like it's more electronic
i didn't know these things existed same
thing
that's rough but yeah some people have
their dicks locked up currently
mm-hmm cause i'm locked up
i'm all for it wow
next one yeah all right it's over
wait wait but would you guys wear one
yeah
so like if i was wearing one right now
would you judge me
like are they do you guys not like them
like what's the problem
i got bitcoin right but have you ever
worn them
you know you can give them different
colors
different colors mine's black i mean
yeah
different color different tastes i mean
have you seen this how about that
when i get off stage with the lap
factory right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this is from a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son